this is a true story I went back home
and we're all drinking and we're on a
mountain I don't know how did you really
clean him out it wasn't like a mountain
like how do congratulations we made the
top of the mountains like a mountain and
it's like a we're on a hill yeah it up
here yeah so up they were drinking we're
reminiscing and then one of my friends
is like saw mattress there was a
mattress there and he goes hey we should
take that mattress and slide down there
I was like well okay that's why you
didn't go to college and I was like no
dude that's a terrible idea it was come
on man I was like all right that's all
it takes it takes one time so five of us
adults fathers two of them have children
get on this mattress and we're all
holding like looking at each other like
it's the teacup ride at Disneyland and
we start going down and at first it's
fun like it's like yay yeah remember
high school like we're having moments on
this like journey sure but have you ever
been like like on a sled or like skiing
and it like hits a speed that you know
is like oh this is like the speed it
shouldn't be yeah like we went from like
fun speed so this is how we die we're
gonna be in a play for like five idiots
maybe a gay orgy who knows what happened
the mattress yeah three more gee I don't
know what happened but what was fun is
everybody was like yeah let's do this
but then like I got really quiet for a
second it was just all you see is snow
and wind is just going and then my
friend next to me who has like a sleeve
tattoo been to jail made a noise that I
didn't know a man could make all this
sudden we hit like a little bump and we
start spinning so that we're spinning so
now we really are on a teacup ride you
know without boundaries and we're going
around and he just goes
this noise like no no help help like
this but then I start doing it I'm like
oh wow
so everybody starts doing it except one
friend like you ever been in a scary
situation with a friend and he doesn't
get scared and you change your whole
attitude about this person yeah this
guy's like a teacher with like a sweater
vest and glasses so all of us are going
well we didn't say that but I feel like
we should have and he just looks like as
he goes hey we'll be fine and I don't
know what it was about the way he said
that but he he owned me like he could
have gotten me to do anything he said
cuz he was like God like we all stopped
him like what do we do
hey looks that he goes on the count of
three we all let go I'm like okay
whatever you say so we all count three
two one and we all let go and that was a
horrible plan that's where it's the
worst idea ever my one friend who went
to prison is just I see him he goes off
a cliff he actually went up a little
cliff but he had like a little jump so
it was like all you heard was no no no
but then but then when you got there
the funniest part is he didn't make a
noise it just was like no no
I got a Irina quiet I got a stump
you